you are probably familiar with magnetic
resonance imaging machines either
through the claustrophobic sensation of
being inside of one or from seeing the
incredibly High detail cross-sections of
the human body they provide MRIs have
completely changed how we View and
understand our bodies it has never been
easier to visualize organs with such
high detail we can safely locate and
identify tumors in the kidneys brain
stomach and pancreas we can inject
paramagnetic contrast agents into the
bloodstream to locate blockages in the
heart allowing doctors to accurately
implant life-saving stents to open blood
vessels a tiny Keyhole surgery that
patients can recover from quickly where
once dangerous open heart surgery was
the only option magnetic resonance
imaging has truly changed the nature of
medical diagnosis and treatment a
technology that seems straight out of a
Sci-Fi novel how they work is a complete
mystery to most to unlock the power of
this machine physicists and Engineers
first had to discover and master the
principles of quantum physics
superconducting magnets Computer Science
and Mathematics this is the insane
engineering of magnetic resonance
imaging the clean futuristic white
facade of an MRI machine hides a world
of complicated and marvelous engineering
that you may not have ever considered
prior to their introduction to Medicine
we peered inside our bodies using
harmful ionizing x-rays or low detailed
ultrasounds while incredibly useful even
to this day these two Imaging techniques
pale in performance to the safe
millimeter resolution of MRIs capable of
creating a 3D reconstruction of the body
rather than a flat 2D image achieving
all of that with without any moving
parts
Imaging in medicine relies on collecting
signals from the body based on the
innate physical properties of tissues
ultrasound imaging relies on how sound
waves bounce off tissues of different
densities x-rays form images based on
the absorption of high energy radio
frequency waves magnetic resonance
imaging however relies on something far
less intuitive the quantum properties of
the hydrogen atom the human body is
teeming with hydrogen atoms located in
water carbohydrates and proteins to
image the body MRI machines exploit a
Quantum property of these hydrogen atoms
a property called spin how it does this
is a Marvel of modern physics and
engineering Sven is an innate property
of particles just like mass and charge
spin makes particles behave like tiny
bear magnets the proton inside the
hydrogen nucleus behaves like a magnet
the orientation of its magnetic north is
described probabilistically under normal
circumstances this probability is evenly
distributed this means the combined
magnetic field of many hydrogen atoms
cancels out but this changes when the
hydrogens are inserted into a large
external magnetic field just like the
ones MRIs create this changes the
distribution of the tiny magnets
augmenting the number of atoms aligned
with the external magnetic field this
imbalance is the source of the MRI
signal we can manipulate these tiny
magnets to produce signals that can be
processed into images once the atoms are
aligned in the machine's incredibly
strong magnetic field the machine gives
them a tiny Notch using an magnetic
radio frequency pulse this pulse comes
from this set of coils inside the
machine that sends pulses by simply
applying and alternating current through
its coils at a very specific frequency
this nudge misaligns these hydrogen bare
magnets to shift their magnetic field
perpendicularly to the large magnetic
field the machine is creating naturally
the spins want to align their
orientation back to their original
position aligning with the machine's
magnetic field but they don't fall back
immediately they decay in a spiraling
motion this Decay causes a changing
magnetic field and by placing a coil of
wire nearby this changing magnetic field
can induce currents that can be read as
a clear signal MRI machines can use the
same coils to send the nudge pulses and
to read the signal from the body these
coils are placed here as close to the
patient as possible but still inside the
MRI tube for higher contrast and
resolution some machines use separate
coils to transmit pulses and to receive
the signal this allows the receiver
coils like these to be placed much
closer to the body maximizing the
strength of the signal we can increase
the number of hydrogens aligning with
the external magnetic field by
increasing the strength of the external
magnetic field in turn the hydrogen
magnets can induce a larger current as
it spirals back so by simply increasing
the strength of the mri's field we
increase the strength of the signal
collected and therefore improve the
image quality common MRI field strengths
are 1.5 to 3 Tesla around 300 000 times
stronger than the Earth's magnetic field
and 30 000 times stronger than your
common fridge Magnus you absolutely do
not want anything ferrous around these
machines during operation a field this
strong can lift nearby wheelchairs
straight off the ground for research
purposes Amores can produce use even
higher magnetic fields up to 20 Teslas
achieving this intense magnetic field
comes as no easy fees early MRIs use
permanent magnets as their source of the
main magnetic field but only reached
strengths of 0.5 Tesla limiting the
resolution of the machines
electromagnets can be used to reach
stronger magnetic fields but standard
electromagnets can't produce a 1.5 Tesla
field higher magnetic fields require
higher electric currents that would melt
ordinary wires to achieve larger
currents in the wires Engineers required
superconducting coils superconductors
are another sci-fi technology
temperature affects all metallic
conductors with resistance gradually
lowering with temperature but
superconducting materials are special in
that their resistance drops to zero at
temperatures close to minus 273 degrees
Celsius or absolute zero in theory when
this happens an electric current could
travel in a loop of super conducting
material indefinitely never needing a
power source in reality this means that
the main superconducting coil in MRIs
does not consume any power directly
rather the main consumption of energy is
just to keep the coil cooled down so the
current will travel endlessly leaving
the MRI magnet permanently on the energy
needed to run an MRI for a full gear is
equivalent to 25 four-person households
around 130 000 to 140 000 kilowatt hours
per year the most common superconducting
material in MRIs is neovium titanium the
demand for high resolution images is so
large that 80 percent of all the neobium
titanium we extract from the earth goes
into MRI machines to achieve the
incredibly low temperatures needed for
superconductivity we need a very cold
refrigerant early MRI machines used to
submerge their superconducting wires in
a bath of liquid helium pouring 1 000
liters of liquid helium at minus 269
degrees Celsius into the machine to cool
the superconducting coil as close to
absolute zero as possible this
evaporated the helium allowing it to
escape the machine as a gas meaning
early MRI machines required regular
refillings of liquid helium even though
helium is an incredibly common gas in
the universe it is so light that it can
escape our atmosphere into space we
extract helium from underground gas
Caverns where it accumulated as a
byproduct of uranium and thorium
radioactive decay but once we allow the
helium to escape into the atmosphere it
is gone for good floating to the top of
our atmosphere and gradually being blown
into space by solar winds we will
eventually run out of natural helium
this method of cooling was costly and
unsustainable costing up to 26 000 per
year in helium refills to avoid this
refilling prop problem modern MRI
machines use a vacuum sealed chamber
that holds the liquid helium without
letting it evaporate this eliminates the
need for refilling and minimizes the
cost of operation these so-called zero
boil off machines are now the norm in
MRI technology they use an electric
refrigerant cycle like the one in your
fridge but on steroids this cycle keeps
the helium in its liquid phase and keeps
the magnets cool enough to maintain them
in their superconducting state
now that we know why and how the
hydrogen atoms are aligned we need a way
to turn that information into an image
and to do that we need to know the
physical location of the hydrogen atoms
recall that MRIs detect signals from the
spiral Decay pattern of hydrogens after
they've been nudged these spirals Decay
with a unique rotational frequency
interestingly this is the only frequency
that can nudge the hydrogens too luckily
rotational frequency is dependent on
something we control the magnetic field
strength for example hydrogen resonates
at 64 megahertz at 1.5 Tesla and at 128
megahertz at 3 Tesla this means the
atoms in a weaker magnetic field will
rotate slower while atoms in a stronger
field will rotate faster to nudge these
atoms we also need a radio frequency
wave at 64 megahertz or 128 megahertz we
can use this to our advantage to image
individual slices
if we apply a gradient to the magnetic
field strength we can selectively nudge
atoms along the gradient by applying the
corresponding frequency this gradient is
applied precisely using a separate set
of regular electromagnets aptly named
gradient coils to image a slice near the
weaker end of the tube the machine sends
a nudging pulse centered at the lower
rotational frequency say
63.998 megahertz and to image a slice on
the other end of the tube the pulse is
centered at
64.002 megahertz this still feels like
magic it's not terribly obvious how
detecting the Decay from the spiraling
hydrogen atoms can create images the
receiving coil can only measure the sum
of all of these spiraling decays we need
a way of processing the signal to create
an image let's start by understanding
how to get contrast between tissues
before delving deeper into the
Technologies used to actually 4 form
images we need a way of identifying
different kinds of tissues to form an
image to do that we need to contrast the
tissues using two different signal types
the first one deals with how quickly
atoms realign themselves with the large
magnetic field after a nudging pulse
this is called T1 relaxation the second
measure comes from the physical reality
of interaction between hydrogens the
atoms do not realign with the magnetic
field uniformly in tissue hydrogens
interact with each other and with their
surroundings right after the nudging
pulse is sent the small interactions
cause the spins to fall out of
uniformity since the coil can only
measure the sum of all of these spiral
decays then the falling out of order
would create a decaying signal this is
called T2 Decay importantly the two
rates are not equal and even more
important they are dependent on the
tissue hydrogens and fat have different
intrinsic characteristics and
interactions than hydrogens in water
this difference is what lets technicians
contrast the tissues we can emphasize
the t16 by sending pulses rapidly and
listening to the signal immediately as
the defacing effects of T2 do not have
enough time to take place we can
emphasize T2 by sending pulses slowly
and listening for longer allowing the
dephasing to occur just like a
photographer can play with camera
settings to take pictures of either the
bright sky or a dim environment MRI
technicians can also play with two
settings to take images of contrasting
tissues the time between pulse
repetition and how long to wait to
listen for a signal these two parameters
are chosen by the technician each time
an MRI is performed and they choose them
depending on what the doctor would like
to image for example T1 is used to image
fatty tissues while suppressing the
signal from water but maybe the doctor
wants to assess the cerebral spinal
fluid in the spine or the brain and for
that T2 signals are emphasized to
enhance the signal from water-based
fluids remember the signal is collected
as a some from a singular slice the
machine needs to form a 2D image of each
slice there is one extra layer of
complexity since the receiver coil can
only measure the sum of the signals from
all the decaying hydrogens in the slice
this is yet another story where old
mathematic discoveries guide modern
technology in 1822 Joseph Fourier
created a mathematical framework that
deconstructs complex waves into simple
additions of simpler waves this
framework can be extended to 2D
grayscale geometries just like a musical
melody can be simplified into additions
of simpler notes any image can be
deconstructed into a weighted average of
simpler black and white stripes this is
what MRI is used to create images
instead of sampling individual pixels
MRI sample different striped patterns in
reality what does this mean for the
spinning hydrogens what is the physical
representation of these pattern Hertz it
is easier if we imagine the slice as a
grid of rotating hydrogens where we
color the face of the atoms in grayscale
when rotating in unison the grid is all
white and atoms rotating 180 degrees out
of phase are colored black mri's exploit
this to physically create the striped
patterns needed for the Fourier analysis
using another set of gradient coils MRIs
precisely changed the phase of rotating
hydrogens to create striped patterns by
controlling how long the Y and X
gradients are turned on the MRIs can
create patterns in all directions and
frequencies slowly the machine starts to
imprint all the patterns with different
frequencies and orientations to sample
their relative strengths in physical
space and slowly by adding more and more
patterns the image starts to emerge this
is what forms the image for each 2D
slice then the machine goes on to the
next slice of the body and starts the
process all over again
turning on and off the coils inside a
magnetic field might sound familiar if
you've ever played with the speaker
they're basically doing the same thing
gradient coils rapidly turning on and
off are the source of the loud clunking
sounds in MRIs MRIs are constantly
evolving and the core technology is
starting to Branch off researchers want
the highest resolution and strive to
increase the strength of the magnets
while some hospitals and companies are
making them smaller and cheaper as more
practical and cheap MRIs are incredibly
useful in the field it's hard to Fathom
the complexity of all these systems from
superconducting wires to vacuum sealed
helium reserves to rapidly changing
magnetic gradients and it's even more
incredible to think of the first people
who figured out how to combine these
Technologies together to peer into our
bodies this intricate dance of quantum
physics and carefully manipulated
gradients has allowed MRIs to change the
world of Medicine
the MRI machine is a truly astounding
piece of electronic technology and
developing something this complicated
would simply not be possible without
diagnostic tools like those created by
keysight keysight put the very best
electronic measurement and testing tools
into Engineers hands and are holding
another virtual event for engineers on
May 16th this fantastic free event is a
rare opportunity to learn about
Electronics from experts this event will
explore performance of batteries DC to
DC conversions and Internet of Things
devices using live experiments like
testing different battery models at
different temperatures to see how that
affects device run types and testing DC
to DC converter performances this isn't
just a live video you can watch and
learn from there will be a live q a
session too allowing you to ask industry
experts questions an opportunity that
does not come around very often and
everyone that registers for the event
will be entered into a draw for
keysight's Mass of gear giveaway they
are giving away 20 pieces of pro-grade
test gear worth over three hundred
thousand dollars these are extremely
valuable professional grade tools and
you will get an extra entry to the
giveaway if you sign up with mylake if
you missed this event don't worry
because you can re-watch the stream and
they will be holding new Live Events
every two months whether you're an
expert engineer or Electronics newbie
you should definitely be signing up for
this completely free event
foreign